speak Japanese
When we first came to the company, we
always
taught basic Japanese lessons. When you first learn Japanese,
it's like all languages, but up to a certain point, it's
very difficult. It's very fun. It's very easy, but then when you get into things like grammar and other difficult things, it
becomes very difficult.
I'm not that
good at it, and I'm
not that great at it, but I like watching cartoons
and
watching Japanese dramas, so I
just
feel like I can remember things I've heard and write like this. Also, if I were to
learn another language, English would be the best.  I
think I want to learn English because it can be
used in many places, so I can still
understand it to a certain extent,
but I think
it would be good if I could speak it more comfortably.